my priorities are simple
kovid
recovery
reform
kovid
getting us and keeping us out of this
pandemic
recovery
tackling the huge backlog of
appointments that it has caused
and reform
of our health and social care systems
for the long term
today
i'm going to look forward
we can all be here at this conference
and talk about the future
because of the success of our vaccine
program
an amazing example of what public
private collaboration can do
of course we cannot afford a single dose
of complacency
this virus has shown itself to be
unpredictable
but so far
our vaccine wall of defense has held
firm
and we will keep strengthening it brick
by brick
jab by jab
with one of the only national booster
programs in the world
we took the difficult decision before
the summer
to put our faith in that vaccine war
before that was possible
as a country
we sacrificed our freedoms and our way
of life to protect our elderly and
vulnerable
the pandemic has been described by some
as a great leveler
that's just not true
health disparities in our society
whether they are regional
racial or socio-economic
they have deepened undercovered
that's why one of my first visits as
health secretary was to blackpool
i remember one of the nurses there
she told me that you know you can trace
back the entrenched health problems in
blackpool going back over a century
let me ask you this
do you know what the healthy life
expectancy gap is between blackpool and
richmond upon
thames it's almost 20 years
it's time to level up on health
the state was needed in this pandemic
more than any time in peacetime
but government shouldn't own all risks
and responsibilities in life
we as citizens have to take some
responsibility for our health too
we should always go first to the state
what kind of society would that be
health
and social care
it begins at home
it should be family first
then community
then the state
if you do need support
we're lucky we live in a compassionate
society in a developed country that can
afford to help you
there are few higher callings for anyone
than to care for another person